nous sommes au chemin et des etam hier à
epône ici se trouve derrière moi le
camion le foot tracker lambour et de
gérants commencent la préparation des
repas du midi nous allons aller les voir
allez suivez moi
[Musique]
j'ai remonté dit bonjour jean receveur
vedette du coup l'un des gérants des
deux camions fuso truck donc du coup ici
ça fait combien de temps que vous êtes
là ça fait sept ans qu'on veut installer
à epône qu'on a commencé l'activité et
ça se passe plutôt pas mal j'ai un
camion qui est du lundi au jeudi à leroy
merlin a dit schleck ok pour tous les
midi et le soir qui promène dans la
campagne tout sur 70 40 hier arnaud
willay menthe et touahri et ce camion là
qui se promènent davantage les midis
entre et aubergenville epône
plaisir parle un peu de votre kart wii
vous essentiellement ce sont les burgers
que vous faites
ils sont donc fait part avec des
produits locaux cela est aussi vrai tout
à fait j'ai un boulanger qui me laisse
tous les jours un boulanger de
versailles là aux délices de versailles
après les pommes de terre c'est pareil
on va avoir vu l'homme en toi qui as la
campagne juste à côté
par rapport à notre un autre emplacement
doit faire à peu près 5 6 km pour les
chercher nos pommes de terre cyberguerre
d'une complètement différent avec des
produits comme le tartare de poisson les
plus demandés ce pôle est etc ça réduit
encore improbable pourquoi bah ça permet
de voyager en fait des hamburgers qui
suivent sont vraiment le fromage à
raclette le lard dont les antilles un
petit peu avec le madras la volaille
mariné au lait de coco curry et pour
ceux qui n'aiment pas eh bien on peut
composer soi-même son regard vers la
version miami où vous avez une base avec
pains viande sauce est dedans vous
mettez tous les éléments que vous voulez
pour composer le burger de votre choix
vous voulez en faire votre blog et va
aller allez on y va ce barça là
ok je suis prête on commence à couper le
pain encore un sac en vain
[Musique]
et donc l'âge mais la sauce la sauce
on en met bien chaque côté elles atebank
charron
et maintenant quelle sauce émises en mai
le steak à cuire sur ce point ça fait ça
en plein coeur
[Musique]
donc on commence par quoi tomates
salades toujours à salem le premier
ouais toujours et a donc remis sa lettre
aux matelas maintiennent
c
vous me conseillez quoi alors g de lait
mentale du chef du fromage à raclette ou
sept semaines de l'ossau iraty c'est un
fromage de brebis ok bon outil pour le
fromage du monde
c'est un
m
[Musique]
free
waouh
m
[Musique]
là
voilà je suis en train de finir de
l'emballer et voilà mon regard était
bon jour là même les petites questions
alors qu'est-ce que vous avez choisi
vous alors il y aura un cheeseburger un
madras et un miami vous avez commandé
quoi vous le burger du jour bernay pour
moi c'est espelette parce que je le
connais bien et qu'il est délicieux et
des habitués en fait là on travaille à
côté donc le burger du mercredi ces voix
là c'est devenu d'anthologie toutes les
semaines on vient quand je peux le
mercredi je viendrai
et si vous aussi vous voulez profiter
des burgers du foutraque lambeaux vous
pouvez retrouver à leur adresse dans
classement par jour sur leur site
internet lambour point fr